you know of course about America first
you know about make America great again
you know about higher American you know
about Mexico isn't sending us their best
people you know about all that crap that
we've heard from the Trump
administration Vox has just finished up
a really good analysis of the hiring of
a hundred and forty-four workers in
seasonal positions at Trump properties
in New York and Florida and of the
hundred and forty four jobs one went to
US workers from 2016 to the end of 2017
the other 143 Trump Organization jobs
went to foreign workers with h-2b visas
when you hire with an h-2b visa you
actually first have to try to hire in
the United States and then if you're not
able to find someone qualified in the US
then you can go to foreign workers these
were positions at Trump businesses for
servers cooks housekeepers and
bartenders not the highest skilled jobs
in the world yet mr. America first
himself can't seem to find anyone in a
country of 325 million people to work
and it's also fascinating how Trump
wants to make cuts to a ton of visa
programs that actually makes sense but
then the h-2b visa which is a way for
American companies to legally hire cheap
foreign labor that visa Trump likes and
in fact temporarily expanded the h-2b
visa program as president which allowed
him to hire even more low paid foreign
labor at his clubs and his resorts this
is a con artist okay and this is not a
story where I am coming to you and
saying hey listen immigration is good or
immigration is bad or h-2b visas are
good or bad or we should have more of
them or less of them what I'm telling
you is that Trump is a bamboozling con
artist who says buy American he says
hire American workers he says America
first he complains that immigrants are
undercutting American workers at a lower
salary
but then he's making the problem worse
here's one tweet okay this is just one
tweet from Trump on this from
inauguration day where Trump said we
will follow two simple rules by American
and hire American hashtag inauguration
day hashtag make America great again so
what's a possible explanation or a
defense to this right well one that we
sometimes hear is and we've heard it
from Trump before Americans didn't want
the jobs well if Americans didn't want
the jobs when you were using h-2b visas
to hire in 2016 and in 2015 and in 2014
the economy must have been doing pretty
damn well under Obama that nobody wanted
the jobs that you were offering at
mar-a-lago or wherever else the
hypocrisy of which is that if that's
true then what he's basically saying is
we need immigrant labor for our
businesses to succeed which then should
inform his policy position you would
imagine but it doesn't right and this is
actually a really good exercise because
it shows us that you can see Trump's
real position on issues through his
business decisions we often say you know
from says this but he also said that and
then someone else suggested this third
position and he said that's actually his
new position the campaign trail
statements the tweets all that stuff it
doesn't tell us anything look at what
Trump has done in his businesses to know
what his positions are he wants to hire
foreign workers because that's actually
his position that that's totally fine he
wants to build a wall not with the u.s.
met not on the us-mexico border he wants
to build a wall around his Golf Club in
Scotland or wherever it was because he
recognizes privately that climate change
could sink his Golf Course but publicly
he says oh it's a hoax created by the
Chinese we can actually figure out
Trump's real positions and it depends on
looking at his business decisions and it
has nothing to do with his public policy
well there certainly are contradictions
there like when he tries to pay the
least amount in taxes that he can or not
hire Americans hi
our immigrants instead I think he would
argue that it's not incumbent on him to
do the right thing it's incoming on the
government to make the policies and I
don't know I've tried to make it kind of
yeah I mean they've said that with the
entire Ivanka's clothes and his clothes
are made in China or wherever right
which is like listen we're playing the
game within the law given the
circumstances of globalization and the
economy let's change the world such that
it's better for us to buy American but
it's just so stupid because if he wants
to do the right thing if he wants to set
an example except the slightly smaller
profit and have the ability to tout that
you're producing your clothes in the
United States right yeah and it's why
I'm so surprised that in 2016 and didn't
really stick that this guy really is a
con man yeah that's the Trump University
stuff and him hiring Polish immigrants
that people didn't really recognize that
stuff when they went to the voting
booths yeah because it's it's a clear
case of that I don't know that it's that
they didn't recognize it
I just think ultimately number one they
didn't care and number two they were
fatigued because it was like a new
scandal every day was a new lie exposed
every single day and this is what you've
got
okay 143 of 144 hired from foreign
countries on h-2b visas today's episode
is made possible in part by a harmony if
you're trying online dating chances are
that you've run into the lazy text
messages the dead-end conversations the
random matches that don't go anywhere
but eHarmony isn't like many other
online dating sites because they take
steps that other dating sites don't in
order to find you a more compatible
match by using years and years of
science and data to help you find
lasting and meaningful relationships and
in fact they've helped over a million
people find their perfect match and
right now our viewers and listeners can
get a free month with harmony when they
sign up for a three-month subscription
if you enter my code this is very very
important PA que ma and enter my code
Pakman at checkout stop waiting and
start your journey to a satisfying and
meaningful relationship e
harmony see how a harmony can change
your life go to eharmony.com and get
started
but you must enter my code Pakman at
checkout